i
love
bread there is so much good bread in
france and although man does not live by
bread alone
without it the meal seems incomplete
on every corner there is a bakery that
is pumping out delicious fresh well-made
bread
this is not easily available to me and i
want to know why why is it that the
bread that i can get easily looks very
very different
why is it that the us sucks at making
bread in fact let me just show you what
that looks like
[Applause]
okay wait it's 12 hours earlier uh still
back in the u.s
i'm actually at a grocery store right
now
[Music]
this is how a lot of us americans get
our bread
psy my favorite part is when they make
this plastic look like it's steaming
it's just like foggy plastic to be like
this was just baked right now and it's
like no this was actually baked like
three weeks ago in a factory in like
connecticut
it's even made with real butter
always buy wonder breasts
you'll be glad you did the reason i'm
purchasing this bread is because i want
to bring it with me to france just to
like have an example lesson and i may
use it as a pillow because it's
literally as soft as a nova foam pillow
some of this bagged bread is made with
ingredients that are literally illegal
in the eu
back to france let's do it there is
nothing more american than wonder bread
i'm going to france
[Music]
in case you're wondering yes any video
from paris must include music like this
nice gentle cafe accordion music there's
my composer tom making it right now it's
pretty cool it's just so good okay so
yeah we know that france is good at
bread and the u.s sucks at it is this
just another video where i [ __ ] on the
usa for being terrible at certain things
yes it is
it's exactly what it is but hear me out
i actually have something to say here i
believe that bread is a really important
symbol for a bigger
cultural phenomenon in the u.s and
that's what i want to talk about today
where industrialized bread came from
why it exists and
how some people are trying to change it
i'll get to that explanation but first
i'm gonna go into that bakery over there
and buy myself a large ball of butter
and flour stuffed with chocolate oh and
tom can you throw in a beat to this
accordion music please yeah thanks
any questions um yes are you going to
finish that quasal
[Music]
oh yeah
pause
my job is to make videos for you and the
reason i'm able to do that is because
there are brands that support this
channel this video in particular is
sponsored by betterhelp and i'm grateful
for that because i deeply support what
they're trying to do better help is
online virtual therapy i've been going
to therapy for several years it has
changed my life but i'm very aware that
it's not easy to find a therapist the
traditional way with betterhelp
technology helps fix some of this you
fill out a survey and then betterhelp
assesses your needs and it matches you
with someone in their massive network of
over 20 000 licensed therapists and then
you start communicating with them like
in as little as 48 hours you can do a
video call you can do just a phone call
or you could even just do a live text if
your therapist isn't a good fit you can
easily change for free and it eventually
helps you find the right fit therapy is
a way to improve your mental health
something that we all need this is why
over 2 million people are on better help
this isn't a self-help thing this isn't
like a crisis line it is legitimate real
therapy done securely on the internet if
you want to try this out at a discount
you can there's a link in my description
it's betterhelp.com johnny harris
clicking that link helps support this
channel but it also gets you 10 off your
first month of better help therapy has
changed my life it could change yours go
check out betterhelp and thank you
betterhelp for supporting this channel
and the journalism that i do let's dive
back into the video okay so why bread
there's a million other things i could
talk about that are better in other
parts of the world but it turns out that
bread is the most important prepared
food that humans have ever made and
therefore it is worth talking about so
let me explain in under a minute the
overview of the tens of thousands of
years of history of bread and its
chemistry and why it's so important
don't think i can do it in under a
minute check this out twelve thousand
years ago humans realized that they
could plant this grass instead of just
foraging for it this grass was called
wheat and when it was ground up with a
stone it made this powder that if you
put water with it creates this stretchy
goopy thing that has a bunch of sugar
from the flour that's been released oh
look wow all the bacteria in the air
love this sugary goop nice and they
descend to feast on it burping out gas
as they eat
whoa the gas can't float up into the air
because it's getting trapped in this
stretchy ball of goop like a balloon
like a pillow like magic magic all this
feasting and burping is making it rise
and turn into a pillowy thing that is
way bigger than it was put this blob
next to some fire and all of the little
bubbles that were just created turn hard
wait all this can happen because of this
one grass yes cool let's plant a lot
more of this grass and build all of
human civilization off of it said humans
[Music]
so that is bread like the oldest and
most important prepared food item that
humans have ever invented eventually
humans got really good at doing this
bread flour water yeast thing and
especially here in france they took it
really seriously and have created a
whole culture around making bread
delicious and amazing
and you can see that they've continued
that culture today just by the number of
bakeries that exist in this city there
are 30 000 independent bakeries in
france compare that to the 3 000 that
are in the united states and then
remember that the u.s has like a much
larger population and if you do all the
math you see that france has 50 times
more bakeries per capita than the united
states 50 times i mean that is such a
clear indication of how much they value
good bread that is baked a certain way
i'm here with mr local over here yeah
local french food in france yes 94 of
parisians live less than five minutes
away from a bakery
[Music]
they care
they care it's like you you hear stuff
like that and you're like uh-huh
this is their priority yeah yeah and the
culture of of eating is just as much
important here as how like the
ingredients are sourced and prepared and
whatnot yeah people don't eat while
rushing towards their next meeting or
whatever like it's very much no you sit
down you may get a thing it's just a
part of the way of life here yeah
people come into the laundries almost on
a daily basis and they check in with
each other it's like uh hey how you
doing you know i'm doing great this is
what's happening why why why why that is
the question why are these bread
cultures so different and the answer
comes down to what america was founded
on i mean a reminder that america is a
country founded by a bunch of people who
left their country to go make a new life
to do things differently to do things
more individualistically and the way
that expressed itself for a long time
was mechanization industrialization and
to be clear in the history britain was
as much to blame for all of this
mechanizing of bread as america was
that's insulting but anyway we're
talking about the usa for a little bit
so by the 1920s you had this machine
that was invented an automatic bread
slicer hello convenience innovation
america
no more serrated knife versus a tough
crusty loaf
now the machine will do it for you
this is the greatest thing since slice
oh so that's where we're at this is the
greatest thing
says america and europe was like wait
yeah we like machines too but like not
for bread
slice this bread and you make your bread
spoil faster we don't need a machine for
sliced bread but the automatic slicer
was just the beginning for america no
i'm just getting warmed up now that we
have sliced bread that yes spoils faster
let's make it i don't know not spoil as
fast one way to do this is to take the
part of the wheat berry that has oils in
it the husk and the bran and get rid of
it
focus on the big carb-loaded berry in
the middle
but there had to be a more industrial
solution to make the bread last longer
to be whiter to be softer and it's the
1950s and europe is like whoa dude
america chill out like bread is just
bread we've been doing this for
literally tens of thousands of years
let's just like stick to the program and
america's like
so america starts adding all of this
stuff to their bread bleaches and dough
conditioners and suddenly they're
putting their bread into controlled
chambers so that it will be hot enough
to rise faster and they're putting
preservatives in so that their bread can
now sit on a shelf for not just one or
two days like it should but four days
five days six days a whole week and it's
still soft it is still white it is still
spongy and delicious but it now has 15
ingredients instead of three and it's
cheap and convenient and stable and
america is loving this and europe is
like whoa
you took this way too far this is not
bread anymore and indeed i would argue
that this is not bread anymore this is a
bread-like substance the different
product made from a different process
and yet we use the same word for it if
you want to know more about what's
inside of this kind of bread i was
actually here making this video when i
stumbled upon a video from one of my
favorite youtubers adam marguccia that's
like a deep dive into all of the
ingredients in this kind of industrial
bread definitely go check it out some
bread in the u.s has taken it so far
that they will put in additives that
keep it spongy and soft or that keep it
really white even though these additives
are known to like cause cancer and
inflame asthma and do all of these
terrible things many of these additives
that are legal to be put in american
bread are literally illegal in europe
and many other countries azo dicarbons
[Music]
is one of them this is a whitening agent
but you know what this product ada
also helps other things stay softer like
yoga mats ada is in yoga mats to make
them spongy and soft and it is banned in
the eu and many other countries our
obsession with convenience cheapness
softness shelf life has led us down a
really dangerous path and yet we're
totally okay with it somehow this is why
i think bread is a useful symbol for
broader american culture it shows us how
far we're willing to go to prioritize
things like cheapness and convenience
over tried and true methods that have
been baked into culture
of course industrialized bread exists
here as well it doesn't have some of the
carcinogenic ingredients that are not
allowed in the eu but it still has all
the dough conditioners bleaches still
artificially risen all of that the
difference is that it is rare it is much
more rare here what is much more common
is the ability to go to your local
bakery and get bread that only has
a few ingredients and it's the
ingredients that humans have been using
for tens of thousands of years to make
this staple food the feeling that i
generally have is that this is how it
should be and then when i go elsewhere
and you have other kinds of bread that
the last kind of bizarre amounts of time
you know you're like this is not really
how it should be you get calibrated to
kind of this new standard here
and it's it's it kind of ruins you turns
out paris is low-key one of the most
bikable cities i've ever been in but it
used to not be like that like last time
i was here it was not this bikeable
i smell some urban design policy changes
afoot here someone tried to change this
in the u.s a few years ago a company
called panera what could be better than
a visit to panera bread tried to bring
like european bread culture to the
united states and they did they had high
quality delicious bread but what happens
next is potentially the best metaphor
for america hello i like money they got
a business loan so they could expand and
then they got investors and they started
to expand and scale and then they were
purchased in a massive merger and now
they're planning to go public on the
public stock exchanges like they just
became a massive corporation who does
not focus on making quality artisan
bread instead they're now just a machine
pumping out bread that kind of looks and
feels like european bread but is now
done in a uniform mass-produced
industrialized process
all in the name of scale and profit
so the question is why does this matter
like am i just being a snob who's like
traditional bread is better and
therefore everyone should have it and i
hate america that was snobby you're a
snob no i'm not kind of yeah but also it
actually makes a difference in how it
goes into your body the beauty of bread
always was that you could put this goop
out in the air and bacteria would come
down and start to feast on it and kind
of start the digestion process that is
what natural fermentation does is it
starts to break down the wheat and make
it ready to go into your body the way
that we make bread in america
doesn't really leave time for this we
use heat and chemicals to speed this
process up to make it rise faster to
make it rise bigger in an artificial
synthetic way and so you're actually
getting a much inferior product to what
original bread making looks like and
what it produces yes it lasts longer yes
it tastes like chewy pillowy sugary
heaven but it's not bread the way that
humans have been eating it for tens of
thousands of years
convenience
scale independence that is what we love
in america we love shelf life we love
industrialized efficiency and to me yeah
all that stuff is super great because it
means we get to live these wonderful
prosperous convenient lives but i think
we lose something really big when we
focus on those as the priorities as
opposed to
quality and community and culture
last thing i'll say here is that this is
slowly changing you have a movement in
the u.s
of people making some of the best bread
in the world using the most traditional
methods and ingredients in these big
cities you have amazing bakeries doing
bread that is on par with anything you
could get in europe
and that kind of blows my mind the
problem is and my critique is that that
is still so rare and specialty and
really only available to people who live
in big urban areas and meanwhile the
rest of us the most accessible bread to
us
is this industrial mass-produced garbage
belongs in the trash and that is enough
to make me pretty frustrated
[Music]